okay we are gonna go to the phones early
this week what with the Thanksgiving
holiday here in the United States a lot
of people want to be heard from 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 is the number let's start with
our caller from the 4 6 9 area code
caller from 4 6 9 who's this what's on
your mind
hi this is Lily from Dallas Texas
alright and we're not on speakerphone or
Bluetooth are we because we're getting a
very strange noise no we're not all
right go ahead low my so I was wondering
will you ever run for office in any
plane in your life also how's that doing
I want to know that it's going it's
doing today Pat's doing great he's he's
working on today's show and I might run
for office in the very far future I
don't see doing that anytime soon
I could never be president of course
because I was not born in the United
States that's that's a limitation I'm
just gonna have to deal with but it
wouldn't be you know I I don't have any
particular interest in running for
office because it seems like it's just
very hard to get things done as a cog in
the wheel whereas I have total control
on the show and an audience that in in
and of themselves can do a lot of
activism that I can speak to so I don't
know I've never ruled out running for
office at some point maybe but it would
have to really be the perfect
opportunity it's not like I'm dying to
be an elected official thank you all
right very good Louis thank you
appreciate the call one of the days
sponsors is privacy comm slash Pakman
which is a free service that I myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy calm then you can
create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one
the best things about it is how their
mobile app and browser extensions for
Chrome and Firefox make it really easy
to use let's say for example that I'm
signing up for a david pakman show
membership in the credit card number
field I already see the privacy comm
icon I just click it choose which of my
virtual credit cards I want to use and
the credit card number expiration date
and security code are automatically
entered I can put in any zip code I want
and I'm done and if you try to use my
credit card number that you just saw on
the screen it doesn't matter because
I've already deleted that virtual card
and that's the beauty of privacy comm
there are a ton of advantages to using a
free service like this for example you
can sign up for as many free trials as
you want then just delete the virtual
credit card you used and never worry
about getting charged for it it protects
you from getting hacked it protects you
when companies are hacked which happens
all the time it is all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time they're giving everyone
in our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link